So the last equation that we'd created for
Grant to tell him how much he would earn
in the future, once people actually paid
for the glasses, wipers, and nozzles they
had ordered, was that his total future
earnings = 84w, where w is the price per
wiper set plus 60n, where n is the price per
nozzle. However, there's been another
change in the situation. In considering
the last change that happened to Grant,
which was the cancellation of orders that
made him really, really sad, this is a
super positive update. First, Grant got a
telephone call from an elderly wealthy
gentleman, named Mr. Belvedere, who
happens to be super interested in glasses
wipers and in the nozzles that Grant has
developed to go along with his wiper
blades. He was so enthusiastic about
Grant's inventions that he offered to
triple all of the orders that Grant had
brought in so far, which means that
Grant's total future earnings, which we
know before were 84w + 60n, will be
multiplied by 3. Then a second piece of
good news came. A school principal called
Grant and let him know that she wanted to
order, one wiper blade set and one pair of
nozzles, for each of her 150 students who
wear glasses. This however happened after
Mr. Belvedere decided to triple the orders
that had come in so far. So his tripling
does not apply to this new batch orders
from the school.